what are we going to replace it with
this is in virginia so we should you
know pick a an actual hero from virginia
to put up there
um
i think but you know so that's the
question is who who is going to be but
my tweet was robert e lee is a sucker
and a loser because he is a [ __ ]
loser
[ __ ] lost he's a [ __ ] sucker
because he
he fought for slavery
uh
this shouldn't be controversial this
this this idea
that it should be controversial to take
down a [ __ ] statue of the confederate
[ __ ] general
who fought
who
[ __ ] traitor who fought to keep
american southern americans to own other
[ __ ] human beings okay
okay it's just so we're [ __ ] clear
here that's
oh
who he was
it's
in 2021 folks it should not be a
controversial thing to take this [ __ ]
statue down
now if somebody wants to put it in a
[ __ ] museum somewhere like a a
confederate you know cemetery or some
[ __ ] and put a big plaque that says this
is where this [ __ ] statue is at this
is why it was there give not just the
history of robert e lee but the history
of the [ __ ] statue and why it was
there
is to send a signal
send a message right
so if if that i'm i'm fine if you want
to place a big plaque in front of and
tell the actual story of that son of a
[ __ ] because what i say
is this should not be controversial it
should not be controversial that we take
this [ __ ] down in a public place
like this
real americans learn their history and
know the truth
if you if you really know the truth
about robert e lee and you really know
the truth about american history you
would not want this [ __ ] statue in a
place
that makes it seem like we are honoring
robert e lee a [ __ ] traitor a traitor
to our country
you [ __ ] patriots out there oh
patriots
the [ __ ] out of here you are not
patriots if you think robert e lee is a
[ __ ] hero he was a [ __ ] traitor
and they lost
and someone posted a video
uh hey let's see